fam on CBS America's most watched
Network airs Thursdays at 9:30 p.m.
Eastern Time and the stars of it playing
in engaged couple we have here on the
Rich Eisen show together tone Bell and
Nina Dobrev well I mean ball and chain
it's gonna happen right I mean I mean I
guess you got to keep watching the show
yeah wedding will happen whether it will
conclude right he's a different story
but we will look forward to that yes
fantastic good to see you guys here yes
you do you guys normally do interviews
together for this show we've done a
couple yeah yeah okay I'm kind of busy
after I've been turban traveling but
you're too busy tone is what I've been
told as a new movie yeah just finish a
pied just just wrapped last week mmm
that's why I have this my Cuban mustache
right now I think it's kind of I think
it's kind of sexy it looks good on
camera it looks very proper and polite
something that I never used to describe
tone right now you look very polite he
usually has like this like an animal
that lives on his face what I'm a
creature am an animal animal animal he
was like it's a good thing is like a
it's an identity which is because I've
never not had never seen him
clean-shaven is that right yeah that's
all I did for ever in my career and then
I went you're the face what with a face
that's an appropriate level of face what
about my face I like the level of scruff
and length that you've got that you're
rocking at the moment you like that
perfectly ratioed right now it really is
it's proportionate to your face and okay
also matches the rent like ever it's
just like equal which is good if the
level of the hair grows past the level
of the the top yeah it's just too much
for me in my opinion which is you're
great keep it the way flashier maybe
I'll keep it no because I'm kidding you
know we have
like you know like kiss on camera faces
if you like sweet I was about to say
thanks for coming I don't think this
interview could get any better for me so
I'll take that I'll take that tone
you're from Atlanta Georgia Atlanta
Georgia
George so which do does that mean you
have a are you a falcon fan or you know
I'm actually a Cowboys I do I do like
the Falcons but I'm a Cowboys fan how
does that happen my for my first starter
jacket was a 5th grade cowboy jacket
Smith harder Jackie well it wasn't a
real sorry I'm saying sorry jacket so
you know what I'm talking about knockoff
B it is a cowboy jacket so maybe the
Cowboys come on for Christmas
why because I was a big game and Smith
fan cool never had there like with him
my dad wasn't really a sports guy either
so watch the Falcons but I'm a Cowboys
fan okay yeah so did you ever get grief
for that is it all the time cuz all my
friends that live here you're in LA and
we all go watch the game I mean
everybody's Atlanta fan so you're still
locked in right school so you mean I'm
bandwagon when we we're out watching the
game okay but then it you know under my
falconeri's they got my Cowboys Jersey
okay very good
yeah I mean now I do now that makes you
a die-hard fan but you've never been in
the beach bowl correct you've never done
anything like that like say they have
stopped doing it yeah you did that you
did that a couple years how how did your
Beach bowl career evolve
Nina um you know it was promising I I
was really looking forward to a long
prosperous career in this arena and I
thought I was gonna really make it like
got the long haul running injury oh oh
look I am talking
Jesse Palmer that's the match ler is he
yeah back in two thousand fourteen years
post The Bachelor we're going through
your career yeah but in the game when I
had a white jersey on the previous game
there's David Arquette I Meghan Merkel
was was in that we played in that game
yeah did she act like royalty at the
time or no I mean what does that even
mean
dainty I don't know she's a classy woman
yeah but she can but she can throw a
ball and she plays football she can get
down you just use yesterday that's a
gimpy and like so so did you follow
Canadian football at all growing up in
any way uniform no I ball in team is as
you mentioned I'm Canadian
no I don't have a like team team I'm
kind of like you I'm a fair-weather fan
of any sort and he sort of hockey
growing up late I I played all the
sports I was never really like a big
watcher of the sports I go go to the
Super Bowl but I'm not that's okay play
hockey did you ever play hockey in any
way shape or form okay so what what was
it what was the Nina Dobrev hockey game
like I mean did you play goalie did you
score goals check people into the boards
I'm trying to figure out what was
important in my early hockey career um
it was me versus my brother and all of
his friends and my brothers five years
older so they were just like patting me
up and throw me in goal and just like
hit pucks at me it was like some people
called it hockey other people would call
the torture it really depends on which
side of the net that you're sitting on
okay
I called it torture because I was in the
net and
a bunch of sixteen year olds using four
days this sounds like a wonderful child
I'm from Atlanta we don't do hockey it's
not it's not really our sport indicator
right but um yeah we the thrashes for I
don't even know we still have a khadeem
be honest with you have no I don't do we
I don't think we Atlanta has a hockey to
do we know that's a no that's a no I
just I just we just spent the whole week
in Atlanta for the Superbowl
yes year I was fine it was were you
there was there okay
it was a blast I live in Atlanta for six
years as well uh-huh we bonded over this
many times I love that city it's so fun
and so great so your food is amazing in
the new stadiums on the line real it is
unbelievable so who are you rooting for
for this year's Super Bowl oh okay so I
win how much I heard that she went okay
so so I also drink a lot this is why I
forgot for a second because the Rams
obviously living like living in LA and I
was I was rooting for the Rams plus the
underdog aspect of it I just really
wanted the underdog to win but then
obviously the paint like it was this
whole debate the Patriots always think
they they they're they don't talk to him
about it the Patriots with Atlanta
that's a four that was a tough and that
it's not even Alana's not even my team
like that but I mean I was hurt by that
one that was and that one was you have
to look back and go this is not gonna
work don't work out I know alright can't
trust Tom Brady man can't trust
especially now that he's on Twitter he
just joined Twitter for the first yeah
whoa news do you handle your own
accounts with the 19 gazillion people on
it you do it or you have somebody do
that for you yeah me and all 19 of my
followers
you can't you can't they're coming back
that's okay
fantastic what's great talk about why
it's yeah we trucking along okay they're
coming on at tone Bell at Nina Dobrev
right now let's talk about fam
Thursday's 9:30 p.m. Eastern Time you
guys have worked before correct together
before the show we did okay so did you
know that you were trying out for the
parts or did you know that you were it's
not it's not like sports you don't try
out for the show pardon me let me start
again I do know better than that let me
see did you guys know that you were
gonna be in the same show together yeah
the super team we did we did like
playing a play nobody was well we worked
here there in the film first and then he
got cast in in the TV show and then they
were looking for the girl and it
suggested me I didn't think they because
we just finished the movie I just didn't
I didn't think that they would be into
it right and then they call like hey
what do you think about Nina I'm like
yeah she down then we hopped on the
phone and and now fam was born yeah and
it's again it's on Thursday nights at
9:30 p.m. Eastern Time
it's been a lot of fun thank you for
coming on this program today thank you
for having absolutely and if the Beach
Bowl ever comes back into existence
you're in right oh yeah I'm definitely
gonna be auditioning for the dad yeah
certainly next years it's in my life
look if there's ever a shot at it that
next year's in Miami where I assume you
probably played in one of those I didn't
I didn't go to Miami
the way it was it know all these super
bowls of yours they just at tone bill on
Twitter at Nina Dobrev on Twitter watch
these two together do their thing on fam
Thursdays at 9:30 p.m. an ally and
wedding is coming up check it out okay
do what do we get you guys what do you
mean for the wedding for the wedding
yeah registered an espresso okay I'm uh
where she didn't even know there's a
register to Amazon so case or I was
gonna for SkyMall Busan I obviously
didn't set that up I got you I got you
don't worry about it on your plate okay
well you're switching it up lil
Restoration Hardware have you say sweet
very good
fams Thursday's at 9:30 p.m. Eastern
Time on CBS the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience